your brain is wired to be rewarded for
things and so you are doing things that
reward you and if you're like well I
don't like doing anything that's
impossible everything we do is because
we've been warded for doing things like
that in the past and we predict that
doing things like we did in the past
that reward us reward us again in the
future and I've lived my life through a
series of Rapid iterations not trying to
pick the right thing even when I was
starting my first business I was between
frozen yogurt test prep and a gym why
were those the things I was like well I
was pretty good at taking tests in
college I like frozen yogurt I mean it
sounds simple but like everybody likes
something I'll do Fitness because I like
Fitness at the very least I'll do
something I enjoy I'm a big fan of being
directionally correct rather than
absolutely correct